every language is a product of its
history and that's certainly the case
when we look at creole languages new
languages which arise as a result of
contact between groups of people who
share no common language one such creole
is papiamento a portuguese-based creole
spoken in the dutch caribbean papiamento
is spoken by around 340 000 people
mainly on the abc islands aruba bonaire
and kurasaw despite their location in
the caribbean sea these islands are part
of the kingdom of the netherlands both
dutch and papua mento are official
languages in aruba in kurasaw while only
dutch is official in bonaire but
papiamento is the most common language
used for daily interaction that might
sound kind of strange why is a
portuguese-based creole spoken alongside
dutch rather than portuguese the process
of how papiamento developed is not
entirely known but it's likely that it
developed from a portuguese creole
spoken in the portuguese colonies of
west africa and was spoken by enslaved
people taken to the caribbean this seems
likely because popiamento bears a strong
resemblance to upper guinea creoles
spoken in the cape verde islands
guinea-bissau and casamance in senegal
with portuguese exploration in the 15th
and 16th centuries came the
establishment of trading posts and
colonies which were part of the
portuguese empire this included those on
the west african coast and cape verde
islands as a result of contact between
the portuguese and africans both locals
and enslaved africans taken there from
elsewhere pidgin languages arose in
order to expedite communication between
the different groups these pigeon
languages consisted of mainly portuguese
words and improvised stripped-down
grammar when the children of pidgin
speakers began to speak a pidgin
language as their native language they
became stable creole languages
these portuguese colonies in west africa
were huge centers of the transatlantic
slave trade and most of the enslaved
people taken to the abc islands departed
from there a large number of them must
have spoken a portuguese-based pigeon or
creole language and brought it with them
to the caribbean where it underwent
further influence the abc islands were
under spanish control from 1527 to 1634
when many people were forcibly taken
there from africa and there has always
been extensive contact between the
islands and the south american mainland
which is just a stone's throw away so
there has naturally been some spanish
influence on papiamento the dutch took
control of the islands in 1634 and have
ruled them ever since so there has
naturally been some dutch influence on
papiamento and there was likely also
influence from judeo-portuguese because
many of the residents of the islands
were sephardic jews from brazil portugal
and elsewhere populamento is generally
considered a portuguese-based creole but
with significant spanish influence as
well on top of the 20 of papua mental
vocabulary that comes from dutch
approximately 80 percent of papua mental
vocabulary is iberian in other words
spanish or portuguese but because the
two languages are closely related it's
not always clear which language a word
came from
some words are clearly from portuguese
here are a couple of examples
meaning butterfly from
meaning power from forza
some words are clearly from spanish a
couple of examples are sombre meaning
hat from sombrero
meaning trousers from
which means underpants
and as i mentioned a moment ago some
words are of less certain origin
meaning which from either spanish
or portuguese
meaning how much from either spanish
cuanto or portuguese
a couple of commonly used words of dutch
origin are
meaning book
meaning apple from apple
as you may have expected there are also
words derived from west african
languages for example meaning teneal
this comes from the wolf word jongoto
there are some words from taino or
arawak the indigenous language spoken on
the islands before colonization though
some of these first entered spanish then
papiamento for example maishi meaning
corn from the taino or arawak word mahis
but which entered popiamento from the
spanish word maith
and there were also some words from
english
meaning bottle bicycle meaning bicycle
and the short word is base meaning bike
here are a few basic greetings in
papiamento bundia good morning compare
that to portuguese
good afternoon compare that to
portuguese
good evening compare that to portuguese
notice that in papiamento the word for
good is bone in each case even though in
portuguese there's both
and
that's because portuguese has masculine
and feminine gender whereas papiamento
doesn't have grammatical gender
one more greeting
how are you
i'm good
kon means how like
in portuguese or komo in spanish ta is
the present tense marker and bai means
go and comes from portuguese
the third person singular form of
meaning to go so this is like how's it
going me means i ta is the copula and
bon means good
kon is a question word that resembles a
portuguese one or a spanish one so are
kua meaning which and cuanto meaning how
much which we saw before this is true
for other question words as well
when this comes from portuguese
or spanish
this comes from portuguese king and
spanish
what this one is derived from spanish k
meaning what in spanish
meaning thing
what are you doing
i'm reading a book
why this word comes from a combination
of spanish para meaning for and the word
we just saw kiku meaning what
what time compare this to portuguese
chiaris
what day compare this to portuguese
of course the spanish phrases are very
similar too
the basic word order in papiamento is
svo subject verb object as we saw in
this sentence
here's the subject here's the verb and
here's the object note that the subject
is a personal pronoun most of the
personal pronouns resemble portuguese
and spanish ones me i this comes from
portuguese
the prepositional form of the pronoun
this comes from portuguese
a mostly archaic second person plural
subject pronoun and or spanish bush a
second person singular pronoun still
used in dialects with boseo
he or she from portuguese
and or spanish
this particular pronoun is not from
spanish or portuguese it's original to
papiamento it might seem strange that
i'm saying portuguese and or spanish
right i mean how could it be both well
words can sometimes have a dual
etymology in which a word originates in
one language and is reinforced by a
similar word in another language
it's interesting to note that while in
portuguese and spanish the subject
pronoun can be dropped in popiamento it
can't that's because in portuguese and
spanish the verb has conjugations that
indicate person and number but in
papiamento the verb isn't conjugated for
person in number
when it comes to verb tenses the
popumental verbs don't normally change
form but a tense or aspect marker can be
placed before the verb as is quite
common in creole languages
this is the present tense marker which
actually comes from spanish
and or portuguese
this is the future tense marker this is
an abbreviation of the portuguese word
logu which means soon it normally comes
before the subject
i will sing but lo is normally only used
to really emphasize the future the
present tense is often used instead
this is the past tense marker it
actually comes from the auxiliary verb
in the spanish present perfect ah the
third person singular form
this marks habitual action or ability to
do something
i sing with the meaning of on a regular
basis or i know how to sing
sa comes from portuguese and spanish
meaning to know
this means going to and is also used for
the future
i'm going to sing
when you came in i was singing
for the present progressive there's
actually a present participle form
that's used
i'm reading a book lesando is the
present participle form of lisa with the
base form of the verb the meaning is
general present tense
i read books
ta the present tense marker can also be
used as a present tense copula like is
or r
their house is beautiful word for word
it's they house copula beautiful as
another quick side note notice how
possession is formed in this sentence a
possessive pronoun is placed before the
noun but all of the possessive pronouns
are the same as the subject object
pronouns except for the third person
singular which is su not a
possession can also be shown using d
plus the possessor dinan would mean
theirs but back to the copula
this is the past tense version of ta
it's used as a past copula if yes
the party was boring word for word it's
the party past copula boring also notice
here the definite article a
one important verb is
which means have it seems to come from
the third person singular present tense
form of the portuguese verb
which is
it could also come from or be reinforced
by spanish tener
meeting
i have 10 books word for word it's i
have 10 books tin is also used to show
existence like there is for example
there's a person at the door word for
word it's there is person at door notice
the word hende which comes from
portuguese shint and spanish
and notice the preposition na which
means in or at and comes from portuguese
the feminine form of in the
tin doesn't use the pre-verbal marker ah
for the past tense just like tabata is
the past tense of ta tabatin is the past
tense of teen
there was a person at the door
it's probably important to point out
that papiamento is spelled in two
different ways in aruba spelling is
based more closely on the words
etymology in kurasawa and bonaire the
spelling is more phonetic in other words
based on the way words sound the
spelling so far has been that of
kurosawa and bonaire let's take a look
at both of them for the same sentence
this sentence means john is going with
me to my grandmother's house and we're
going to eat some fish creole
notice the difference in the final vowel
in juntu next notice that the k sound is
represented by c in aruba but k in
bonaire and kurasaw and notice the word
for and is spelled with a y in aruba and
an i in bonaire
now let's break the other elements of
the sentence down word for word it's
john present tense marker go together
with me to my grandmother her house and
we future tense eat fish creole tabai is
the present tense of go huntu means
together and comes from portuguese
or spanish
means with and comes from portuguese
or spanish
means my grandmother's house willa comes
from spanish abuela which means
grandmother su is used to connect the
possessor and the thing that's possessed
literally it's my grandmother her house
but in natural english it's my
grandmother's house lokome is the future
tense of the verb meaning eat pisca is
the noun meaning fish but it comes from
the portuguese and spanish verbs
meaning to fish
now let's break down a couple more
sentences
this is the book which i bought word for
word it's this present copula the book
which i past marker by
izaki means this and comes from spanish
este this plus aki meaning here ku is a
relative pronoun meaning which or that
it comes from portuguese
and or spanish
means by and comes from portuguese
in spanish
and one final sentence
i like this house but it's too expensive
word for word it's i like the house here
but it present copula too expensive
gusta means like and comes from spanish
gusta
next ikasaki means this house in the
previous sentence we looked at isaki
meant this but when we need to say it in
a phrase like this house then it's
phrased as the house here
pero means but and comes from old
portuguese peru or spanish peru muchu
comes from spanish mucho and means much
or many as well as tu
karu means expensive and comes from
portuguese
and could have been reinforced by
spanish karo
as you can see papiamento is a lot like
other creole languages with the majority
of its vocabulary coming from its main
lexifier language portuguese but with a
lot of grammatical simplifications and
with different spellings and word forms
that make it immediately obvious that
this is not portuguese and then there
are all the other influences that
collectively help make papiamento
something unique of its own the question
of the day for speakers of papiamento
what differences do you notice between
the different varieties of your language
as it's spoken on the different islands
and for other people what's your
impression of papiamento leave your
answers in the comments down below and
it's time to say thank you to all the
langfocus patreon supporters especially
the top tier patrons whose names appear
right here on the screen many extra
special thanks go out to them learn how
to become a patron by visiting
patreon.com
langfocus and to everyone thank you for
watching and have a nice day
[Music]
you